As app developers, it's our job
to maintain the illusion
that once started, every app
is waiting patiently in the background
looking for its chance to be the star
when called on.
So whenever the user switches back
to your app, whether or not the system
is killed during in the interim,
they should be presented
with the same UI they had when they left.
To help, Android has a pair of handlers
specifically for persisting state
in these circumstances.
OnSaveInstanceState is called
immediately before onPause.
So, as soon as your app
is no longer active,
an onRestoreInstanceState
is called immediately after onCreate,
but only if the app is being restarted
after having been terminated
by the system.
That means you can read the bundle
of state information saved the last time
your app was moved
to the foreground here.
The next time,
you'll use the switches to your app
even if it was killed by the system
in the mean time.
Using that bundle, you can return
your UI to the same state it was
the last time the user saw it,
creating a seamless transition
that hides the resource management
happening under the covers.
That's enough of the "why,"
let's go back to Dan
and see how to put this theory
into practice.